[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you America help you win
in your life specifically with your
money your relationships and your work
the phone number is 8825 5225 it's a
free call
88255 225 I'm Kim Coleman John deloney
joins me this hour and we've got uh the
good doctor is in here so this is your
mental health and relationship uh expert
and then I'm in the work space here at
Ramsay so we don't have a money
personality on but that doesn't mean we
aren't going to take money calls because
we are we're going to take your money
calls your work rated calls and then
mental health by the way they all work
together John and I were talking about
this the other day uh about how if your
work life is sucking you're going to
drag that home with you and if if your
home life is on fire you're bringing
that to the office so all the calls
money relationships work mental health
today we want to help you you ready to
go yeah and by the way if your money's
not going well there's no way you can be
well that's correct no matter what
you're doing if you're driving to work
and you don't know if you have the money
to put gas in your car your work day is
not going to be great right it all works
together man absolutely right so let's
start it off with Barbara and Reno
Nevada they tell me not Nevada Barbara
how can we
help hi hi Ken hi Dr John how are you
thank you for how your guys good we're
having fun what's going on with you
today um well first I just want to
appreciate you saying Nevada right I
gotta tell you I've said it wrong enough
to finally get it right it's Nevada even
though I want to say Nevada it's
Nevada awesome so the reason I'm calling
in is
because um I have committed plenty of um
Financial infidelity trying to help my
father who's disabled um he has little
to no income and um it's becoming a
problem obviously in my marriage because
we're now in B step two we're wanting to
you know knock all this Deb out but at
the same time feel kind of
emotionally I don't know tied like
wanting to help my father but like
wanting to stay faithful to my you know
my finances so what has happened up to
this point give give the good doctor
here uh a bit of a sample of what
Financial infidelity has looked like up
to this
moment so my fathers come to me for
loans um and you know not we're not
talking like big numbers like thousands
of dollars or anything like that but you
know maybe in like the hundreds range um
but like we're my husband and I are kind
of like low income so it's it's a big
deal when we loan out you know a couple
hundred dollars
income um right now uh it's we're a one
income household and um we're shy of
39,000 why are you a one um income
household um so I'm a stayhome mom right
now but um I just uh I got I had a work
injury and so um I've been kind of stuck
at home you know what kind of work
injury so I hurt my back at
work can can you get a job working from
home uh I was I'm looking into it but um
the main thing is that like with my dad
it's kind of become a little bit of like
I don't I don't know if emotional
manipulation become kind of like a
strong no listen I just want to stop
right there 100% of this is on
you yes I agree so what your dad is
doing what he knows to do which is to
ask you for money and he gets it from
you and so if if you cut that off or if
you say Hey Dad it's not a good time
he's going to use whatever tactics he
knows and if he was on the phone I would
say stop doing that but the fact that he
gets an exchange money comes from your
account to him he he plays no part in
that you give it to him for whatever
reason okay so whether he's manipulating
you being mean talk whatever you are
handing him the money and at the same
time you're choosing to lie to your
husband about
it you're absolutely right so I want you
to full ownership same ownership is and
the reason Ken's asking you about what
does this look like and I'm asking you
about working from home is it's real
easy to get into this well I can't do
this and I can't do this but I have to
do this and I just think there's a big
box of bull crap to most all of that
yeah you can get a work from a home job
millions and millions and millions of
people have done it yeah in fact her
answer to your question you asked her
point blank can you and you said barbar
we're not picking on you but your
response was well I'm looking into that
when the answer answer was yes or no and
the answer is yes unless the kids are
eating up all of your time but you
worked prior to the back injuries so the
question becomes now how long before the
back is healed when does the doctor say
you can now resume whatever your PR
previous duties were the point we're
asking here is you've got to make some
changes number one we need more income
at this point in Reno Nevada in 2023
with you have the ability to work at
home or in the office your choice
there's no way you guys should be making
39,000 gross that's separate issue from
you giving your dad money but either way
we've got to make some really clear
changes in our life and it's also easy
to get buried by shame you do one you
don't tell the truth one time and then
that's piles onto this and it piles onto
that and so what I want you to do is to
begin to think of yourself imagining
yourself standing up on your own two
feet and saying I'm taking control of
all of this now have you has your
husband asked you point BL like where's
all this money and you're like I don't
know and you you've lied to him or you
have you just done this thing
quietly so um I my husband and I started
talking about it a few months ago maybe
more than that um because obviously like
things started to get tight and it was
like oh well how come we can't you know
afford that and then you know I had to
kind of complain about it and so now
we're kind of on you know I've told them
like I'm going to put my foot down cuz
you're absolutely right um I the onus is
on me like I'm the one that needs to
have the backbone to be like you know
I'm sorry Dad I can't and that's true
because we don't we don't have the money
but I do agree with you guys I
definitely need to um get us you know uh
job from home um I'm not opposed to that
at all um so he to answer your question
my husband is aware he's he you know
we've I've made we've made an agreement
together that I'm not going to fall back
on that I'm not going to you know feel
um uh what's the word like I I'm not
going to do that anymore Barbara one of
the things that you guys probably should
do is a budget if you guys done a an
every dollar budget using our world
class app or the point is a zerob based
budget where we're going to spend every
dollar on paper because this is an extra
layer of accountability if you're both
communicating on the budget then the
agreement that you just made or you
mentioned has more teeth have you guys
done this I'm yes so we have a budget um
we actually need to um plug back into
the dollar every dollar app yeah because
there's not a line item for Dad
anymore right or if there is or if there
ISE we're GNA send 50 bucks a month and
that's what we've agreed on I if my dad
was disabled and could not eat without
support I would have a hard time not
helping okay yeah of course I would have
to sit down and be honest with my wife
about it and not lie and hide about it
and maybe I can't send him 500 bucks
like I want to but I can do 50 and I
would recommend you and your husband
getting on a phone call with Dad so
you're both on the same page and say Dad
we've done a budget we can no longer
afford to support you we can do this or
we can't do anything and that's the way
it's going to be moving forward so
you're both on the same page Dad can't
pull anybody's heart strings and then
y'all can get lined up and go forward
together but you got to get a job ASAP
thanks for the call Barbara don't move
folks more of your calls coming up this
is the Ramy
show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different softare Ware systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data net Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ram show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dr John delone we are
here for you this hour the phone number
to jump in Isle
8825 5225 that's triple
8825 5225 let's go to Omaha Nebraska now
where Jack awaits Jack how can we
help hi so I'm 19 and couple months ago
I had gotten back from vacation with a
family and my car well my previous car
was a Ford Fusion 2017 i' bought it for
$115,000 I took out a loan probably not
the best idea uh and within a couple
months I had the engine overheating all
the time and head gaskets started
blowing so that car I had to like end up
fixing which ended up costing around
like two to three
grand and then there were just one issue
after another and by uh July of this
year I had to trade it in and was about
8 ,000 under on that car
loan and everybody that was helping me
find cars and everything ended up
telling me that it would be a great idea
to get this Hyundai Tucson 2020 which
probably shouldn't take other people's
advice that aren't in a great position
but uh but I did and now I'm having a
car payment that's right around
$500 a month six or 7% interest and the
overall loans
$28,000 and I'm just curious what you
guys think the best route would be to uh
get out of this
situation okay do you have any cash at
all uh I've got a th000 cash then I've
got right around 18,000 in Investments
what kind of
Investments uh stock market just uh
normal ETFs like uh S&P 500 bti and QQQ
and stuff okay well uh because these are
stocks this is not a retirement account
cuz people call all the time on the show
and they'll ask us should I take money
from my 401k or retirement accounts to
pay off debt and the answer is no
because uh you're not getting dollar for
dooll there uh and you're hurting your
investment strategy but in this case
with the stocks uh as volatile as they
are we absolutely in this case would say
yeah cash out those stocks that's 18 of
course you're going to take a little hit
on that uh but that's going to allow you
to make a huge dent in this car and and
then uh my guess is you could knock this
thing out with that kind of a headwind
what kind of income do you make
uh right now I'm making about uh 700 a
week after tax okay all right so what do
you do for a
living uh HVAC and then I got a
part-time gas station job all right is
that part-time gas station job included
in the 2,800 net per month uh yep okay
what are you doing for HVAC you only
2800 bucks I'm surprised you're not
making more money I had some AG fat guys
out and I sneeze and they charged me
$2,800
right so uh I'm a first year guy I've
been here for four months now and I'm
just working on new residential
buildings so I'm just making that base
are you in an apprenticeship hour uh yep
yep so I'm gon to be starting school
actually two weeks from now okay is that
the only debt you
have oh yep oh uh 200 on credit cards
but I pay off I don't carry a balance
month to month okay but all right John
you
want go ahead sorry no no go ahead uh I
am thinking about canceling the credit
cards because the cash back it's
1% that's a game that uh that's a game
you're going to lose 100% that's a game
that smart people came up to come after
your money not saying you're not smart
but you did buy two dumb cards in a row
so you're smart your track record with
the money is not cancel those cards
immediately dude just get rid of them
and I would sell all your stocks and
this is um what we call a knucklehead
tax and you're 19 years old dude I've
made stupid decisions with money um way
way older than you so you've learned
your lesson here don't take money advice
from broke people right don't borrow
money on depreciating assets it's just
such a dumb dumb thing to do and um
right
man do when you start this
apprenticeship when you are you going to
go up in salary that is so low that's I
don't know how you're eating is what I'm
saying um yes so I started off at uh,
1550 an hour the first like two weeks
okay and they bump me up to, 1650 and
then just last week they bumped me up an
extra 50 c okay all right I think you've
got a path forward is that what you want
to do you want to be in that HVAC
space uh yeah because I know there's
definitely money to be made
after it takes some years in any kind of
trade to really start making good money
yeah let me tell you what I would do if
I I would I would bounce on the uh gas
station job as soon as we replace the
gas station job so you need every every
nickel coming in right now cuz we want
to knock this out but uh with your skill
set um your your handy enough
intelligent enough two things that I'm
not to fix an HVAC system there's a lot
more hourly opportunities for you out
there using your hands working multiple
jobs if you're a laborer for for an
electrician or I don't care I would be
in those trades working as much as I can
because if you take that stock uh the
stock dividends you're to cash the stock
out I would pay this truck off and
you're going to be out of this thing
pretty quickly if you get very serious
the question is can you put $1,000 a
month I'm just taking minimum $1,000 a
month uh towards this debt could you do
that yeah yeah because the my only
expenses right now I don't have to pay
rent because I live with my dad uh great
so right now my only expenses is phone
bill and car than Insurance yeah I mean
be working like a mad man and knock this
payment out so get rid of the stocks
immediately put it towards the car loan
and then get that car loan on a white
board or on your mirror and that's the
number and you go okay if I put 1,000
or500 or 1,200 or 2,000 a month that I'm
paying this thing off and the nice thing
is you got a decent car pretty nice car
actually and you've paid it off and to
John's Point you're not going to go down
this road again hey here's what I would
do if I were you to Ken's point this
Saturday right after Thanksgiving
actually Friday after thanks giving
Black Friday I would print off 500
flyers that I will do all sorts of I'll
hang your ceiling fan I'll put up your
Christmas lights I'll help you get your
tree in and I'll throw away your tree
when we get done and I would quit that
that that job dude you can rack up some
cash because you know what my wife said
the other day over Christmas break hey I
need you to hang these two ceiling fans
I need to change these three light
fixures out and dude if some kid knocked
on my door some 19-year-old knocked on
my door and said hey I'll do that for
350 I would hire you right this second
yeah right to come in on a ladder hang a
ceiling fan and you know how to do all
that stuff if you want to drive to
Franklin John and I have jobs for you
right now kid don't do that don't please
don't do that don't drive here we've had
people do we had people take us
seriously I just realized exactly but
listen I would go fly your neighborhood
the day after Thanksgiving and I'm
telling you you're going to get some
jobs yeah enough to quit that that
secondary job and you're going to be in
people's homes you're going to be
practicing some of those skills you'll
use as an HVAC guy it's going to be
fantastic work yeah you can do this man
so you got it and here's the deal St
today get rid of the credit cards okay
let me just walk you through how long
you been listening to the show or
watching oh man at least a little bit
before I was uh 18 so probably like a
year and a half all right so are you
familiar with our baby
steps yep all right then that's what
you're doing here you're in baby step
two you've got the thousand in savings
don't touch that the stocks okay and
then you're getting after it two and
three jobs like John said and once you
get the car paid off now you're going
into baby step three let's get three to
six months of your expenses in the bank
and then after that 15% of that check my
friend and then you're off and running
and you're going to be a millionaire a
millionaire HVAC guy who maybe owns his
own company and creates jobs okay that's
that's how close you are to changing
your
life you got it and when you do this
you're going to start a company and I
want you to take care of the 19 and 20
year olds who come and join your company
when you hire them I want you to sit
down and walk them through what
Financial Freedom actually feels like
cuz you're going to be on the other side
of this love that uh Jack you can do
this we're cheering for you uh no more
listening to people who are broke on
their car ideas that just never works
but uh he's going to have a paid off
Hyundai pretty soon yeah and it's 2020
it's going to last another decade it
really will fantastic it really will
great stuff all right he is Dr John
deloney I'm Ken Coleman and this is the
ramsy show don't move America more of
your calls coming right up
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show Dr John
delone joins me I'm Ken Coleman and we
are here for you this hour 8825 5225 hey
uh folks it's turkey week Thanksgiving
is going to be here just a couple of
days and uh well Ramsay's joined the
craze I mean let's be honest Black
Friday some of you people live for this
your big deals well we've got the Black
Friday G uh deal going on now how about
that early access to some of our best
deals of the Year great gifts for family
and friends as low as $8 all audiobook
gift cards are $8 gee whiz John we spent
a lot of time in the studio reading
those things doesn't matter Dave just
sells all our stuff gee whiz shop all
the best selling books out there uh for
just $10 each Financial Peace University
also at the lowest price of the year at
$59.99 uh Rachel Cruz and all of her
wallets and 73 colors she has more
colors of that wallet than Crayola has
crayon
all of those are there and of course
John speaking of more colors and Crayola
the quest of for humans 2001 edition as
in the 2000th edition of those cards uh
those are also available the popular
Christmas edition I hope there's a uh
Christmas Vacation question in that I'm
not not crazy of course there is okay
good and you can get all of those great
gifts at uh uh Ramy solutions.com ramsy
solutions.com store and while you're
perusing hit some of the Coleman
products cuz I have two teenage
boys and so is that a sympathy ask you
absolutely better believe that's why I
head to the woods and and bring food
home myself cuz I got one well you got
one and he's got the Hollow Leg already
I'm sure today's question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services when you want to repair
maintain or improve your home stop
wasting time scrolling through pages and
pages of providers neighborly is all you
need or remember for a nationwide
network of local Home Service
professionals visit neighbor.com Ramsey
toind a reliable helper near you all
right today's question comes from Marie
and Arizona Marie writes my husband
charges me 41% of my pay for rent and
utilities
H what wow lovely fell I think we can
stop right there I do too
wow I I do you do you want me to read
the no you and I are friends we hang out
you know how rare it is that I'm
speechless and I'm just trying to think
of what it would be like if I sat down
with my wife and said uh I've done the
math you owe me anyway I work 30 hours a
week and only make
$35,000 there's so much wrong here we
went through FPU so I have been debt
free for years but my husband has never
really been debt free you didn't go
through FPU I used about $80,000 to pay
my husband's debts to help him be debt
free several times over the past s years
but he doesn't stay debt free he even
racked up 14,000 behind my back I refuse
to pay the debt off after that I don't
have the money to help him nor do I want
to we keep our money separate now till
he cleans up his debt and learns to
handle money it's hard for me to save
money when I'm paying him that much of
what I make but he said if I had to go
rent an apartment I would pay that much
or oh gez or more I feel
stuck wow
um this guy needs the whiffle ball bat
treatment yeah there's very rare smack
him around a little bit jeez this whole
thing is a wreck U Marie if I was you or
you were my sister or you are my close
friend I would tell you to um head
directly to a marriage counselor or a
therapist by yourself not a marriage
counselor because he's not going to go
cuz you're you're married to a
seven-year-old who has um access to
adult toys in adult financial
institutions and I would ask how do I
begin to separate myself from this
marriage because this is somebody who
has cheated on you over and over and
over and over again over and over again
and
um there's no way this doesn't just keep
happening and so you're right if you
have to go rent an apartment you'd pay
that much more anyway cool then that's
what I'm going to go do and it's very
very rare that I tell somebody that but
this is somebody that I guarantee you I
I'd be willing to have a lot but i' be
willing to bet what I got that this
isn't the only thing that he is um
cheating on you um this is not the only
way he's cheating on you um I can gu
does feel abusive to you yeah 100% that
this kind of add this kind of behavior
doesn't happen if there's not an alcohol
issue if there's not a drug issue if
there's not somebody on the side issue
if there's not some emotional
psychological abuse this is a wreck yeah
this just this doesn't happen in a
vacuum like this and so um just the
language you're using tells me you have
had to se separate yourself from this
marriage while being stuck inside of it
to keep yourself safe and keep yourself
fed and keep yourself housed and it's
time for you to be able to breathe and
to walk in your own home and drop your
shoulders instead of tensing up even
more so um I'd go sit with a
professional and begin to ask that
question and if he comes around and says
oh she's serious then good on y'all I
always love a last second um uh
everybody decides we're going to be
grown-ups but Marie you are you're an
abusive mess here and it's time it's
time to go sit with the professional Asa
um John I'm not a fan of separation and
certainly not divorce I know there are
cases where it needs to happen this one
feels like um I'm glad you told her to
go see a therapist uh my question
putting you on the spot
is um yes for her but I would tell her
tell me if I'm wrong push back here I'd
tell her in in the course of doing that
to go ahead and separate for the point
of there's no longer going to be you pay
paying him 41% of your pay for rent
utilities we're going to separate until
he gets a of reality this is crushing
her they're already living separately do
you have a problem with that no in fact
um that feels like he needs a wake up
call a 30-day separation just to Cle Let
the Smoke Clear is often really good and
when you do that you want to have um for
lack of but terms of contract here's
when I'm coming back here's here's where
we're going to meet at for lunch to talk
after 30 days but yeah um this guy's
living a delusional life that she is
continue to duct tape um yeah together
for him so that he can keep flexing and
walking around Arizona as though he runs
stuff um it's time for her to get out of
this because this this kind of crap
escalates and it just gets worse and
worse so it's tough I hate this for you
Marie thank you for the question Marie
uh Brian is up next now in Jackson
Mississippi Brian how can we
help hey guys thanks so much um I hope
I've got kind of a fun question here for
you um I'm excited about it so uh my
16-year-old son
um started started off cutting yards um
actually this past summer cut enough
yards that he's sitting with a couple
thousand dollars in his bank account he
bought a zero turn mower so he could cut
more yards faster I'm a little his own
money um he has he's done an incredible
job all that while being in ban in high
school and doing B camp and all the
practices and everything that he has
with that uh so he's doing really
awesome with it
um and now because of his hard work
ethic um the church that we're at has um
hired him to be their custodian um which
is about a about a maybe a 10 hour a
week job and he makes $200 a week so
he's making really got an opportunity as
a 16y old kid make really really good
money between that and his yard business
go Dad yeah you're dad of the Year too
man good for you because that kind of
stuff doesn't happen in vacuum he's
watched his old man work ear hard so
good for you man well thank you thank
you I appreciate it and he's he does
really well when he gets busy he hires
his younger brother sometimes his
younger sister to come help him um hey
Brian we got we got about a minute and a
half we want to help you out what's your
question my question is he I've talked
to him about investing everything with
that he doesn't know for sure what he
wants to do about college but he's got
grades and bans things that'll help a
lot with scholarships but uh he wants to
do something good with this money that
whether it's College whether it's years
down the road for a you know for a down
payment on a house whether it's you know
whatever it is he wants to be smart
because he's going to be making more
money than the 16y old needs so um
trying to help him guide him along with
that I would get him a high yield
savings account uh not just your Bank
savings account I would shop around uh
my wife and I have got a great uh high
yield savings account it's paying us uh
close to 6% right now uh so I would park
that money because of what you just said
he's got a lot of options and so I
wouldn't be investing that right now I'd
be piling it up stacking it up uh in a
high yield savings account to get the
most out of it right now the interest
rates are a really great place for that
so show him how that's working uh just
keep feeding that engine you know he's
got he's tasting it he's seeing it and
I'd keep feeding it just showing him hey
right now we're going to stack it so
that you can use it any way you want to
as we get a better uh a better view if
you will of his future but you're good
dad Brian it's a good kid right there I
got to get me his zero turn problem is I
have a
posted it's a lot of fun oh I'm coming
out to your house this weekend this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your healthc care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramy show where we
help you win with your money your
relationships and your work all three of
those need to be in sync for you to live
a fulfilled peaceful enjoyable life and
we want to help you do that the phone
number is 8825 5225
8825 5225 Dr John deloney joins me I'm
Ken Coleman and we are here for you this
hour let's go to St Louis Missouri Roy
is there Roy how can we help hello
hi well uh I guess let me start um I'll
start with the worst I was recently
diagnosed with a rare cancer I have
about three and a half to 5 years life
expectancy wow my wife and I just before
the diagnosis I knew this was coming at
the time I had no insurance we got a
medical
divorce and we put uh everything that I
had of value went to her so the home was
in both our names it is in her name we
had two Ral properties that are now been
moved to her name also a small business
that we have uh that was newed to her
name she took uh my retirement from a
job and what we put together back and we
have about $26,000 in credit card debt
combined together and I have a student
loan for
$7,500 we have about
175,000 put back for retirement and
about 10,000 in
cash so my question
is what debt should we we also have
helck I'm sorry Helu for
40,000 my question is is what debt
should we approach first and if I were
to die before my debt was paid off she
would be not responsible for it are the
rentals are the rentals cash flowing are
they paid off are those also debt uh
they're debt uh they they they pay for
themselves they cover the uh the
mortgage they cover insurance and tax
taxes and some basic upkeep each year so
walk me through I just want the full
picture here before John and I weigh in
give me the two rental homes uh the debt
plus what you think you could get for
them today let's go rental home one
rental home one I owe up we owe we I
guess or she owes around
40,000 and I believe it would bring
120 okay number two Ral house number two
um about old about 43
mhm and it should bring about 120 as
well they're both exactly the same size
square footage same footprint and let me
make sure I heard you correctly those
are spitting off just enough to take
care of your your Basics you're not
really in the profit once you look at uh
improvements and things of that nature
corre um maybe allog together a piece
maybe $1,000 a year they clear $1,000 a
year both of them combined clear yes
okay well um okay uh let me make sure I
got everything else we have the lowest
debt you have is a $7,500 student loan
next is the 26,000 credit card debt if I
got that right correct and 40K in um uh
uh excuse me thank you okay so and we
have 10,000 in cash are you familiar
with our baby steps before I walk you
through this I don't want uh yes I've
been listening to the show off and on
for several years and I'm all over the
place on the baby step all right so let
me just give you the basics CU this is
going to walk you through what what we
would tell you to do so first thing we
say is we put $1,000 in the bank uh
which is just a basic starter emergency
fund you've got 10K right now okay then
we would say baby step two is we go
smallest to largest debts we pay off the
smallest debt first that's for momentum
purposes so that means we would take on
the $7,500 student loan whatever the
minimum payment is on that we would roll
that that into the credit card debt next
once we paid off the $7,500 loan so we
go smallest to largest that means debt
one that we go after first the student
loan debt two the credit cards debt
three the HELOC does that make sense so
far yes okay great so based on what
you've given me we've got 10,000 in cash
we're going to take 9,000 of that
leaving you 1,000 you still with me yes
and we're gonna pay off the student loan
soon as the phone Call's over that still
leaves you $1,500 you're still tracking
with me yes I am excellent so then we're
going to take the $1,500 left over and
we're going to put it on the $26,000
total debt so if those are multiple
cards then you would you would go it
that way do you understand what I'm
saying so is that all one card or
multiple cards equaling 26 two different
cards all right what is the debt on each
of the two
cards
uh one is around
11,000 and one is around 15 okay great
great so we're still in order so we're
going to go we pay off we take the nine
out of savings pay off the student loan
we have 1,500 we put towards the $1,000
credit card all right and now that
knocks that down to 9,500 if I'm keeping
score properly all right so now you're
off and running now John uh I would sell
one of these these rentals uh
immediately if not sooner and and I
would wipe out the rest of this just
given the situation with your health uh
and what you guys are trying to do
that's what I would do you don't have a
lot left on these homes uh but what I
would do is sell one now this is me John
can weigh in here in a second I'd sell
one of these and if they're both worth
around 120 your numbers 40,000 in in uh
is what you got left on the first one so
that leaves you about 80 minus your
realtor fee so let's just say I've got
65 60,000 I'm going to pay off uh the
rest of the debt and if I can most of
the other rental home you see what I'm
saying I'm cleaning all this up so that
my wife has no debt at all as soon as
possible we're not going to wait 3 years
we want to get after this now that's
what I would do John I I mean I
can't I can't I can't emphasize this
enough that you're like you mentioned it
you're all over the place who who gave
you this is I've heard of this on the
periphery but you're the first person
I've talked
to who who who walked you through this
medical
divorce
um I've been reading about it and we
went and talked to a lawyer and that's
what we uh kind of came up with at the
time where I was diagnosed I did
not have great insurance at all and when
treatment started in
2022 me not be able to work I had
nothing I eventually qualified for you
know Medicaid MH which is taking care of
all my medical debt so far
um and I just wanted to protect her and
I had been reading where people where
spouses had died with hundreds of
thousands if not millions in medical
debt from an illness and I knew about
this
illness in
2021 so I was trying to prepare her and
myself for worst possible
outcome I just I'm just trying to
picture myself having to sit down with
my wife and come up with either side of
of a pretty Grim calculation right yeah
and I'm 56 and she's 62
so you know she doesn't have quite a few
more years to work and you know and of
course you know we don't want my outcome
is so um I was just trying to protect
her the best that I could I didn't want
everything we tried to save over the
years just
uh go away and be are you confident that
there will that they won't come after
her anyway or at least try tangle her up
for years in legal
proceedings um according to our lawyer
they cannot come after her because
whatever debt icur now if I had medical
debt you know I'm just
me wow what a yeah it's just such a
disastrous state of the world we live in
right now that that's the yeah that's
the choice but um that's not the purpose
of this call and so I just want to tell
you we love you and I hate that you're
going through this I mean you're you're
staring down the you're staring on a
very short Runway here and I I I want to
applaud you for the nobil being Noble
and trying to think of everything I
cannot tell you this
enough minimize or minimize every and
all variables sell everything you can
pay off everything you can your wife may
not want to be a landlord after she
loses you at least give her that rental
house paid off at least give her her
current home paid off pay off all of
your debts that you can and that means
yes K like Ken said sell one of those
homes clear up every single variable
possible even if it's not as
advantageous you want to give your wife
as smooth a sailing as
possible tough call thank you sir we're
praying for you this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money your
relationships and in your work
8255 225 is the tollfree number 8825 522
I'm K Coleman joined by my colleague
good pal Dr John deloney we're here
taking your questions we'll take your
money questions but when we're together
we love to take those work questions
those those relationship mental health
questions all of this stuff is
intertwined so no shame in your game
today um we're here for you 8825 5225
Tucson Arizona is where we start this
hour Michelle is there Michelle how can
we help hi there thanks for taking my
call you bet so we my husband and I
bought our house about three and a half
years ago and it's a custom in my dad's
culture to buy the house for their kids
but he couldn't afford it at the time
and now three and a half years later he
can afford to pay off our house for us
and I'm just wondering if I should take
that money and pay off the house or do
something else with it what
culture uh Lebanese culture okay and so
how much is the
payoff about 320,000 and he's got the
cash correct man that's not in my
culture I was going to say I need to
call my culture committee and get that
thing switched man that's that's
incredible John can you take the rest of
this call I'm going to go step outside
and call my dad no kidding I got a high
five when I bought a house my dad was
like get him guys that's amazing uh so
is there any so let me ask this I think
I understand your question but it feels
like there's a question behind this
question yes are you concerned about
something are you wary of how to do it
tell us what you're rattling around your
are there strings with this money
yeah well uh you know he's the house is
in our name
already you know take the house our the
house is in our name so it's not like he
can give us the money and you know take
the house or anything but um he does
like to brag about giving the money but
that's not really you know I'm not I'm
not too concerned about that um I just
wondered if there was like a way to
invest that money and take you know and
make like an income off of monthly
income off that money I mean I don't
know I'm not very smart with investing
well let me ask you this well first of
all the answer is yes of course what was
the amount of money again three what 320
okay so um the question is is Dad giving
you a gift of 320,000 to do whatever you
want with or is he giving you 320,000 to
pay this house off so that he can tell
everybody in my culture this is what we
do and I've now done it correct second
one well and I I so the first that takes
the question off the table that you
asked us it's not an
option yeah and by the way I would not
if if somebody if I had 320 left on my
mortgage and somebody gave me a gift of
320 I'd take it I would put it on my
mortgage way that's a massive investment
that's that's the ultimate investment
then you have freedom you can do
whatever you want you have no house
payment right and then everything you
spend on a house payment you can invest
however you want to for the rest of your
life because you don't have a house
payment yeah yeah it's pretty neat have
you ever been in a house that you owned
that that nobody to take from you no
yeah exactly well hold on a second I got
to bring the good doctorate on here now
I may be reading into this Michelle tell
me I do not mean being wrong I have
three teenagers and I've been married 25
years basically my whole life I've been
wrong okay but it feels like when we're
telling you this John's laying this out
and you're like yeah that's pretty neat
it doesn't feel like you think this is
neat am I right or
wrong well I mean it would be nice if we
had the money to pay off our own house
of course it would of course do you feel
then that it's not okay now I think we
got something you don't want this you
want to feel like we did
it right I mean my dad bought me a car
when I turned 18 he's like you're not
touching my car and that's my car and
don't take my car all right okay that's
that's the strings we're talking about
if he's goingon to give you that and
then he's gonna say whoa whoa whoa you
put your daughter in a nicer School than
that and you and your husband say no no
we decided on this public school and he
goes no no no I paid your house off you
put that kid if that's going to be the
life you're signing up for I wouldn't
touch that
money because then you're trading you're
trading um being a slave to a mortgage
company to being a slave to somebody who
just gave you $320,000 and thinks they
have a they just bought a claim into
your
life yeah I mean he says he wants me to
have peace of mind and he's he's a lot
he's actually changed a lot especially
having grandkids now he's a lot softer
around the edges so but you wouldn't be
calling us if there if you were not
nervous about taking this check well of
course I mean that's a lot of money yeah
but is this how serious is this is this
him telling you you think he's going to
weigh in more uh and you want him to
stop weighing in or is this or is this
just I don't I want to be a big girl and
do it on my own which one is it or is it
both well I I I mean I would like to do
it on my own but at the same time I'm
not going to tell somebody you can't
give me
$320,000 all right but then answer the
other issue are you is you think it's
going to give him more uh entree into
your life to make a comment here and
there if he does this I mean maybe a
comment here and there but I don't think
he's gonna I'll tell you what I got a
lot better so you called to get our
opinion yes of course all right I'll
give you mine real quick um that issue
lies with
me if I had an opportunity my dad
because of his culture wanted to give me
the money and this was something he did
I would take it
and I would go you know if he makes a
comment at Thanksgiving or makes a
comment at Christmas or he comments on
the kids school or the kind of car we
buy I'm just going to smile and wave my
favorite line from the movie Madagascar
the little penguin smile and wave boys I
just gonna take the high road and go
$320,000 Deb free house $320,000 I don't
know I'm going to I'm going to take it
to my professional friend there that's
what I would do unless you know so I'm
thinking of Dave Ramsey came to me and
said hey uh John you've been a faith
employee for X number of years I'm going
to give you
$350,000 oh and by the way um you're now
on call
247365 I wouldn't take that money I've
been on call for 20 years I've lived
that life I'm tired I want to go be with
my family so I would tell him hey thanks
I appreciate that that'd be the money
would be awesome I could do some great
things with it but it's not worth
selling part of my soul if he called me
in and said hey here's $350,000 you've
been a great faithful employee I've
loved your work and I just I just see
you here for the next decade and just
wanted to honor you and your family I
would do summer salts out the building
and probably my shirt would fly off as I
ran to my car screaming and yelling and
cheering I'd be that happy okay and so
only you know what the strings are with
this
money right and if it if you're saying
no because I just want to do it myself
that's ego that's what I'm saying flush
that down the toilet man yeah that's how
people stay chained to like car payments
and and student loans that's ego my kid
got into this school you can't afford
that school we're gonna make it work
because that's
ego if it is no my dad becomes a third
adult in our household I'm not touching
that money and I by the way if if if
that's if it's not a resentment thing I
would do it and i' if I would put up
with all of his stories let him crow you
know sing yell scream about how he paid
your house off what if you were able to
give your kids 32 I would I would be so
happy I would want tell everybody 100% I
was able to help my kids out like this
that's Legacy I don't hear anything
Michelle that says you shouldn't take
the money I'd take the money I really
would uh maybe maybe do a little
Monopoly money Humble Pie and eat
it I I would pay the house off instantly
I go Dad this is great you're the best
you're the man I'm calling my dad right
now me too wow this is the Ramy
[Applause]
show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt s ball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney the phone number to jump in
is8 8255 225 88255 225 okay so our
fearless leader old Captain my Captain
James child's um he emailed John and I
earlier today he goes guys uh there's a
viral video that I I want to uh have you
guys weigh in on so James uh set this up
for us because we've not seen it yet so
what what's going on yeah it came up in
one of our content meetings this morning
and it seemed like the perfect thing for
you cuz it revolves around work okay and
it's it's one of those things where you
watch it once and you have a certain
reaction and then as it sinks in you're
kind of like there's a deeper thing
there so I didn't want to set it up too
much more than that but all right let's
roll it
work until we have to die just for the
privilege of being alive we have to work
somewhere just to afford a house that
we're never at because we're working to
afford the house is the meaning of life
to work and pay taxes and then die on
top of that we also have to work to
afford our vehicle to get to work in
other places and afford gas just to get
to work and we also have to pay taxes
for our roads to drive on to get to work
and then we have to work for our
children to go to school to learn how to
work so our children know how to work
for their children so that their
children can go to school and go to work
like somebody tell me that this is fair
like is it lazy to just want to enjoy
life like why do why do we have to work
why I'm stressed I just check my student
loans because I need interesting so this
went viral you said yeah okay well okay
couple things John
um I I can see the tendency for some to
just you know lay into this young lady
and the snowf flaker and and and and
these things and I've seen some of these
before and have made those comments but
I I got something a little different
here I don't
see lazy spoiled entitlement although I
could understand if some see that I see
uh a little bit of desperation and I
think I see a whole lot of no
understanding and that's not her fault
here's what I mean by that I don't think
the adults in her life and I'm not just
laying out the parents here
but we adults in her life whoever we is
we've not done a good job of explaining
that there is
contribution that is involved with work
yes we've got to work for provision does
that
suck sort of kind of if that's the way
you look at it right but I didn't see I
saw sadness I saw a lack of what is the
whole point of all this I want to enjoy
she goes should we enjoy life I think
the answer is emphatically yes
but I think when we see work as just
this thing to get a
paycheck and it's going to
suck uh and I got to just muddle through
it and the way she laid it out I do
think that's the way a lot of people
look at work I mean I we did a
curriculum at Ramsey Solutions uh that
that that we talked about this with high
school students and I asked about the
dream job and I said what does that mean
to you and to a kid they said it's this
idea of this thing I'd like to do but I
have no chance of doing it so if you
look at that then the idea of enjoying
work and showing up and doing something
that is Meaningful when you do your show
and you meet people in a place of pain
and you step in with them and you give
them hope I mean that's rewarding and I
just don't think she's been taught that
there is a reward to work Beyond a
dollar and I think we failed in that
regard I'm going to say that yeah and I
think I think if the only places you
work are
soulless giant corporations that you
know the only thing you're contributing
to is a few people at the top getting
rich you're not you haven't connected
what you do to you're not solving a
problem for somebody y um you are a cog
in a machine you are a car in a traffic
jam then that sort of desperation Rings
true and I get that y um I've had to
explain to people who aren't in our
ecosystem like I've had to go develop
Hobbies because I like work because I've
always tried to be about solving a
problem for somebody right and I like
doing that and so it it here here's when
I get Crossways and when I just sitting
with people who struggle with mental
health
challenges when I have a day off and I
plan quote unquote I'm going to do
nothing I'm just going to do nothing
tomorrow inevitably about 11:00 I am
about a th000 calories more in than I
normally am I feel miserable my neck
hurts cuz I've been Ling camini watching
some stupid show that like we were not
made to do nothing you say this better
than anybody we're made to contribute to
something bigger than we are and this is
a voice I think generationally that I
wish politicians would listen to that's
right we don't have a Lost Generation of
quote unquote snowflakes we don't have a
because if you if you work with these
they work hard and they weirdly care
deeply they just have come to understand
oh we are playing some body else's game
we're contributing to nothing other than
getting our boss another retirement home
and I'm out I'm out they've done the
math John they have they realize that
the average American they don't walk
around saying this but they've watched
their parents and grandparents work what
amounts to about 990,000 hours in their
lifetime and they get laid off and
they're going they get dropped they get
they get cancer and they're like oh
that's it that's this is it this what we
I think this group has a chance to
transform work as we know it absolutely
but uh as I've said million times if you
spend the majority of your day using
what you do best these are things you're
good at yeah to do work you enjoy to
produce a result that you care about
right that's really rewarding and you
can't to get up and go do it again you
can't um you and I both we share this I
mean you stick us on a stage where we're
answering questions with real people
we'll stand up there for hours well you
and I fly across the country and leave
our families that's how much we
l% and so what is that so that's for for
us that's helping people with that but
for other people it's welding right for
other people it's teaching for other
people it's being in a hospital and
being bone tired and taking one more
surgery because you know that you can
help and you love it I sat with some
guys from Hiller electric I don't mind
call them out they came to my house when
our power went out and my power is
connected to our well so we had no water
we had no power and those
guys wake up every day and say we can
help a family have a better day today
and they just keeps them going and going
they have purpose behind the way two is
it is it hot yes is it exhausting yes is
it the worst yes and there's a purpose
died to it that's right and so I think
here's my dream I wish every leader
whether you have five people working for
you or you're run a huge restaurant
chain and you have
50,000 you're not just making Burgers
you're helping this person find a little
bit of margin in time and eat so that
they can be with their kids or they if
you connect your even your front level
employees to how we're helping somebody
today yes people get they you just
become a part of it here's what I wish I
could do I wish I could hop in the car
with her and go hey tell me what you're
really good at do and we'd hear and we'd
hear some awesome things and we'd say
who are the people you really want to
help or what are some of the problems in
the world that make you upset and and
you would be rewarded if you solv those
problems and you begin to paint a
picture that she has a unique design
plus a unique story that tied together
she's got something where she goes I
would actually be really rewarded and
fired up to go do that oh and by the way
make some money have some life balance
leave work at work yes go home love with
my friends travel the world yes do some
cool things give some of that money to
somebody or like terara the person who
Tak care of our calendar if you ask her
what do you put on Earth to do to be the
best executive assistant who ever lived
yeah those kind of things make me want
to pull my fingernails out I get it and
every day she wakes up and she's like
I'm going to go make this I'm going to
do the best job I can and then these
guys are going to get where they need to
go and they're going to get to be with
their families and like it doesn't
matter what your what what what jazzes
you up doesn't have to be an Instagram
real so but go find that thing culture
what we've done here and adults what
we've done here is we've given these
kids the wrong picture of life it's not
work 90,000 hours hope to have enough
left over in your 401k that that's when
I get to enjoy life we're painting an in
complete picture to buy the fanciest car
to get you to the job no it's work for
contribution and adjust your lifestyle
of that I keep coming back to every time
we have these discussions to the largest
millionaire study ever done by Ramy
Solutions and teachers a median salary
in the United States right now is 61,000
and arguably one of the worst workplaces
in America right now they're they're
leaving in droves but they're everyday
millionaires why they make peace with
the Corolla that's it you nailed it they
make peace with a Corolla it's a great
car get me to and from I'm going to go
help kids and they're fine with it
because they know they're turning on
light bulbs every day and kids that
they're teaching are changing the World
appreciate the video James that really
is a big Grand try to track her down on
Instagram let's have her on the show
wouldn't that be great to actually have
her on that's a brilliant idea this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and utters to motorized Shades they make
it easy and affordable to upgrade your
entire home and their team is ready to
help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John delone joins me 8825
5225 we're here to help you win in your
life specifically your money your
relationships mental health and your
work so you can make more money get in
the right seat of the bus whatever it is
we're here to take your questions today
Triple 8 825 5225 every dollar is our
worldclass budgeting app that helps you
manage money the ramsy way every dollar
Works wherever you are iOS Android uh
Android uh or online you can start for
free and just get an idea of how easy it
is you get organized stop overspending
and save more money if you're new to
every dollar we show you a long-term
Financial road map track your net worth
your debt free date retirement date baby
step progress and so much more it's like
your awesome Mentor right there on your
device and we'll coach you to win with
money and build wealth download the free
app for IOS and Android or go to
everydollar.com everydollar.com to get
started all right let's go to Alberta
Canada Kim is with us now Kim how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call my
question is how much of my income should
I set aside each month to start and
build a business so that I can leave my
to5 okay give us a little bit more of
your um your side business picture how
much is it making how much are you
making in your day
job so I haven't started the business at
all oh okay um so all right so let's
look at your current income so what do
you
make sure so I make 130 a year and my
net monthly after I pay all my expenses
is
$6,000 okay so 6,000 left over after all
expenses and do you have any debt I have
no debt wow okay what is this business
that you're looking to
start so I'm kind of back and forth
around two ideas one is a digital
marketing agency and the other is a
property management company for vacation
rentals okay and uh how much time do you
see yourself having to put into those
businesses think of A and B so digital
marketing a and let's call a property
management B how much do you think you
have to put into those to get those up
and running
much time how much time yeah
probably uh I would say at least like 20
hours a week 20 hours a week and then
how much
money and how much money I think that my
startup cost would be
$56,000 okay and then I would have
probably 1,500 to 2,000 each month just
depends if I wanted to run like targeted
spot like Facebook ads or something that
would make my costs go up okay and are
you single married what's your
relationship
status I'm single on my own okay I like
I rent a three-bedroom house for $2,300
a month but then I rent out the other
two bedrooms so one is a larger bedroom
with two twin beds and I rent those out
for $750 each okay and then I have a
third single bedroom I rent out for 950
so my rental income is like 2450 a month
and then I pay the landlord 2,300 so
yeah you're doing great my only other
question is vehicle yeah no you're
amazing I know that so uh before I tell
you what I think on this the 6,000 that
you have left over after all expenses
that include you uh investing 15% of
your
income that does not do you have an
emergency fund of three to six months
expenses I'm on baby step three right
now great okay so I would fully fund
baby step three and then I would move
into baby step four and be investing 15%
once we achieve those uh two things then
I would I would save up you're going to
save up very quickly the uh I think you
said $66,000 5 to 6,000 what you think
is a startup cost I would save up the
startup cost and I would also save up
six months of operations before I ever
launched I really would I'm very
conservative on that but the reason is
is because I want you to have stressfree
startup for a side hustle you know it's
hard enough to start a business there's
so many different potholes that we know
that entrepreneurs go through in that
first year of the business and I'd love
for you to be pretty stress free to go
this is kind of burn it in the middle of
the table money I know that I'm
investing in me and this business and so
I've got that set aside and and with the
margin you have and the discipline you
have I think you can do that and that
and I want to get John the way in here
and I that leads me to this last piece
which is um I you've got to choose on
these and I would spend some time I
wrote a book called The Proximity
principle that I'm going to give you as
my gift and it just simply says this in
order to do what Kim wants to do she's
got to be around people that are doing
it and and I want you to have have
hangout time with copious notes from
people that are running both of those
businesses before you choose and before
you launch does that make sense like sit
down take them for a coffee yeah so
let's say John let's say John right here
was a digital marketing stud and I mean
he'd been in business for several years
crushing it I'd want to sit down with
John lunch and coffee and I mean I'm not
doing much talking other than asking
questions and I've got a pencil and I've
got a notebook and I'm going John how
did you start what kind of cash did you
have when you started uh what what were
the what were the hardest things you had
to deal with what were the traps what
are Best Practices I mean I'm going to
basically do a college level research
paper on ideally a couple people that
have won in those two businesses let me
tell you why I'm going to get all the
information I need for my head and then
my heart's going to ultimately decide I
think I think you do both of those your
heart's going to go ding ding ding ding
ding ding or when you hear the good the
bad the ugly John your thoughts on that
yeah how does that hit
you yeah that's a good idea I haven't
sat down with anyone in Property
Management um I know some people who run
digital agencies I could talk to them
and here's what you're probably going to
find you're going to find either they
say I wouldn't do this again for
anything or they're going to tell you
like when people ask me like about my
job I just tell them like I feel like
I'm running a scam like I I can't
believe I get paid to do the work that I
get to do and property manager going to
tell you dude it's amazing it's a
headache over here it's really great
over here but incredible or they're
going to tell you please for all that is
good in the world don't do this job you
know what I mean but if they say that
Kim follow up why because what you've
got to what I'm trying to do here is get
The Head and the Heart aligned the the
head is the logic Gathering yeah you
think it's going to cost 5,000 bucks you
don't really know we don't know and so
we want to have a real good log let the
brain do what it does best gather
information logically walk through it
but then let the heart decide and you
might have someone go well listen you
can make this you can make this you make
this but I'll tell you what if I had to
do all over again you know whatever and
you go I don't really care because I'm
not wired like you I think I'd love that
so that's the process that I want you to
gather gather gather gather and and it's
it's a selection process here's the
other reality you might sit down and do
both of these and go it's not it's
neither one of these which by the way
great because you're still stacking up
money and you've got an entrepreneurial
desire in you to work for you yes yes
then the
selection is so important but a lot of
entrepreneurs get we get enticed by
opportunity a opportunity B and we go is
it opportunity C that's what I want you
to do all right Ken I want I'm gonna ask
Ken a question Kim on your behalf is
that cool sure Ken how many people that
you've talked to over the years are like
Kim they make an Astound a great income
sixf figure income they've kind of
figured out life a little bit not afraid
to have roommates make the extra money
not afraid to not tie or identity to a
car and sometimes when we get settled
psychologically We Begin we're wired
we're not wired for settling we're wired
for perseverance and we start looking
over the next
Hill and I hear this all the time quote
unquote if I could just do this
full-time whatever this is and there's
this fantasy that if I wasn't doing this
other thing if I wasn't married to her
anymore if I wasn't U living in this
house then and what I always tell them
is whoa whoa whoa no matter what you do
you go with you and it might be fun to
dream about and she might even get one
digital marketing client and be like
yeah but she's making all this from a
platform of she makes $135,000 and has
health insurance and has all the stuff
worked
out how often do you have people jumping
ship too soon to this quote unquote
magic land of doing this fulltime to the
tune of millions it's called the Great
regret we all heard about the great
resignation what people didn't pay
attention to is how many millions of
people left for a better job this better
life this better check all these things
got there and they were like oh that's
not what I was looking for so it happens
a lot and that's why it's a great
question that's why Kim I really want
you to do the work Let The Head and the
Heart connect and align and when you get
the ding ding ding then we move this is
the RZ
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John delone joins me and we
are here for youle
88255 225 if you got any
work related questions you're not making
the money you want to make maybe you
feel like you've been overlooked or
you're feeling burned out those burnout
calls as you're thinking about next year
uh John and I love those calls there's
there's there's really two sides to that
coin we'd love to take any of those
calls your mental health relationship
questions Dr John in session today and
of course your money calls feel free to
call us we're here to help you guys 8825
5225 Colin is up next in St Louis Colin
how can we help
hi um so I'm 25 years old and I had a
question on if we should pay off me and
my wife should pay off our truck or save
the money um we have a 2-year-old we got
married two months ago and we have
$6,200 left on the truck um our take
home pay per month is about
5600 um but with another baby on the way
at 9 weeks uh we don't know if we should
go into St mode or go ahead and pay it
off yeah well congratulations on the
little one coming that's exciting stuff
the baby's coming in nine weeks or she's
nine weeks down the road nine weeks down
the road okay all right so we've got
6,200 left on the truck is that the only
debt you have uh we have her car but we
are going on stor mode for her car
because it's it's a little further out
well give us give me the whole debt
picture then real quick
okay uh no student loans we're cash
flowing that um and basically just the
truck and the car I think we owe 11,000
12,000 on her car and 6,200 on my truck
uh but her car payment is uh basically
270 a month and uh mine's close to 800
yeah well uh we we normally give this
advice so we want to make sure we
batting down the hatches we be we want
to be very smart for the baby so what
would you say uh do you know what your
out- of pocket would cost uh for the
delivery and all that have you done your
homework to see okay what kind of cash
would we need Beyond
Insurance yes so uh her insurance she's
a teacher so basically her insurance is
really good uh it's 5,000 out the door
and we have that set aside
already well what do you think John I
mean he's got the 5,000 you never know
other costs so what do you do for living
man I'm I'm a carpenter carpenter so let
me throw option three at you and I do
this thought experiment to just for
myself me and my wife do it all the time
if I ever feel like I have an either or
I always invent a couple of other
options just in case I'm not I'm not
cornering myself on accident so let me
give you an option three what if you
continued as a carpenter to stack money
up and we talked about this on an
earlier call and Friday after than
Thanksgiving you wallpapered your
neighborhood with um odd jobs and so I
tell you this like my wife um asked me
to hang up a couple of ceiling fans and
change three or four light fixtures and
then at the top of our in our upstairs
area a light went out so I got to get a
big ladder to go fix it if some guy
knocked on my door Friday morning and
said hey for a couple 300 bucks I'll
I'll do these odd jobs I would sign it
that
second and what if you put a number
you've got nine months okay eight and a
half months what if you put actually
that's not math seven months what if you
put a number I want $ 10,000 extra doar
and honey I'm going to put the gas pedal
down and I'm going to work eye jobs in
the morning in the evenings on the
weekends and so when baby comes we will
have this cash stacked and we're going
to be debt free on both
cars okay uh so I guess maybe uh a
caveat to that is I do have the cash
from odd jobs to pay off the
truck okay and you also have the cash
for the $5,000 out the door for the
pregnancy and the delivery correct yes
we we have 20
$22,000 liquid at this point dude lead
with that next time pay the C pay the
pay the truck off you're fine I I was
going to just follow John and say look
in your situation financially um I
wouldn't stop paying on the truck or car
at all I didn't know you had it in the
bank I definitely pay off both today
because that's 17 and you still got five
left over plus the five for the for the
delivery So you you're covered for just
a a standard pregnancy you're still
going to have five left over and what
are you paying so your car payment
you're getting a big raise from those
two car payments yes I what are you
doing I think part of our problem is
we're living with our with my parents
right now so she's ready to uh a nest
essentially or start nesting and looking
at a house or something to rent well
that doesn't change any advice we'd give
you because you don't need to be taking
on renting and all the stuff if you
still got debt and you've got this
little situation here you could pay this
off today then you can go rent right pay
it off today and then we go rent because
you got a nice deposit get your wife an
apartment get out of house yeah I I love
this idea John with the idea of the year
that's the Christmas price Merry
Christmas hand her some keys to an
apartment oh yeah buy a fancy box have
no debt and then you're making what
6,000
bucks a month right 6200 oh wait wait
wait wait take home is
5600 yes including side jobs yes right
John's already painted that picture I
mean dude you're a carpenter is that
what I heard yes dude you have more work
than you could possibly do yes hey hold
on you're making 5300 take home with her
job and your
job uh 5600 between the two of us and
not including that's that's me full-time
and her fulltime you're not charging
enough
man and then uh the side jobs bring in
anywhere from five grand a month to
nothing you're not charging enough
dude well either way you know your
Market out there I'm hoping that you're
charging what the market rate is in St
Louis but listen you understand what
we're telling you to do you cut the
check for 17 grand a check for 11 and a
check for 6200 as soon as the Call's
over now you're going into a second
child with no debt at all and you still
got 5,000 in an emergency fund for baby
step three 3 to 6 months you already got
5,000 set aside in the stor fund you
guys are okay man and let's get that
emergency fund up over the next s months
I agree that imery fund would be the
would be the
insurance on anything
happen I'll I'll let her know I'll let
her listen to this and we've uh that's
I'm so glad I'm so glad I was worried
we're worried because if we don't have a
lot liquid we feel like we're we're
scared we're terrified if you do what
John said and put a flyer up all over St
Louis saying experience trade Carpenter
for
H dude no job too small you would be
inundated put it on Facebook Marketplace
in your
neighborhood okay hang Christmas lights
yeah anything I'll go get your Christmas
tree and then I'll come pick it up after
Christmas I'd give you a million dollars
for that job just kidding I hate dealing
with an old Christmas tree but D like
it's just like endless amounts of work
right now if if you'll go out and get it
you sound like somebody who hustles but
here's a here's a rule of thumb if you
can enter into this next kid you've got
$10,000 in the bank plus the five that
you've already set aside so this is you
earning another 10 grand right
and you're able to find an apartment
that y'all can afford don't go get
something knucklehead but y'all have an
apartment you can afford um dude you're
you're just good to go you have no debt
you don't owe anybody anything you got
$10,000 that's three months emergency
fund you got a new place and you've got
all the the the thing paid for let me
give you a little little nugget here I
think this may help Colin if if your
girlfriend or wife excuse me if your
wife is like hey I don't know about
paying off the 11,000 just say hey babe
this is how much of a raise we're going
get when we get rid of those two car
payments and that's going to go towards
your new apartment like Bob see you see
where I'm going cuz she may push back on
that but you got 22 in the bank you're
still going to have five left over and
oh by the way babe it makes it easy for
us to afford that apartment she's going
to be so thrilled to have her own nest
that's how you win that deal if there's
a little push back yeah I don't know I
don't know if that's going to work or
not but feels like it would work I just
think it'd be pretty good she wants a
nest it'd be pretty cool yeah and I
think I just one time I rented a house
my wife and I thought my wife thought
she was coming to move into a residence
hall and um I rented a house and it's
one of my greatest Christmases ever I I
got on that I put a Christmas tree in it
and said Merry Christmas and uh pretty
you're such a romantic Dr
deloney that's what they used to call me
the Romantic the no one's ever called me
that act not one time never ever all
right folks great hour thanks to James
Charles our fearless leader and my
colleague Dr John delone in you America
this is the Ramy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life
specifically with your money your
relationships and your work I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Dr John
deloney
8825 5225 8825 225 I got to point out
John uh we have a fabulous studio
audience today greatl looking group of
people that have traveled in from all
around the country waving at us and I
want to remind you folks that we're here
Monday through Friday check the schedule
at ramsy solutions.com and we'd love for
you to come by on your way to whatever
you're doing or if you just want to come
hang out with us you're welcome we've
got free coffee and baked goods and and
it's always fun getting out and saying
hi to the good folks uh that are in the
lobby even showed up here with a George
camel to t-shirt on I don't even know
what to psychologically I don't even
know what to make of that and then it
got worse cuz then we had to pose with
it oh man George is going to print the
picture of us posing with the dude
wearing his shirt true we're never going
to hear the end of it he's going to put
it up in his yeah living room the whole
thing it's really true so anyway we had
to swallow our pride for that but that
just proves we'll take a picture with
anybody because if you're wearing a
George camel t-shirt and we take a
picture with you I mean that the bar
isn't getting L there was an Ohio State
person that you you ushered them off the
stage she was very kind she was very
kind that's true uh and so it's the week
of the big game it's turkey week uh
hunting week for John deloney it's all
of it how many hours are you going to be
in the woods this week do you have I
basically am feral from now until
Christmas okay I like that folks he did
shower I can tell you I'm in close
proximity he smells delightful so let's
get to the phones Jack is with us in
Detroit Michigan the Motor City Jack how
can we help hi guys thanks for thank my
call you bet what's up okay so about
last August my girlfriend and I bought a
house together we're not married I'm 26
years old she's 24 years old and we are
now separating um we bought the house
for 385,000 um we put five 5% down and
so now there's about
$26,000 left on the on the mortgage or
in equity and 360 left on the mortgage
and so basically my question is
uh I I you know I'm I'm torn between
selling the house and either trying to
buy her out through like a loan
assumption or a loan modification sell
the house and get out get out sell the
house and get out get out yeah okay you
both are on the you both are on the home
right the loan yes yes we are where's
she at on
this have you had a
conversation yes so she's I mean she's
basically you know whatever whatever I I
wanted to do she wants to get out you
know as soon as possible as well sell
the house and be done you're 26 years
old and you'll have another house cuz
here's the alternative you're GNA if you
meet somebody and you get married she
going to want to move into your old
girlfriend's house
no no probably not yeah sell your house
dude learn your lesson don't buy a house
with somebody you're not married to I
was going to say Jack I mean if you're
able to sell this house and just split
that last little bit of equity with her
and y'all walk away you've you have
dodged and bullet like the Matrix Man
okay yeah I I've had some Realtors come
by and so they they're we bought it for
385 and they're they want to list it for
three or 450 and they think it could
sell anywhere between 450 and 500 I
would have it listed by this weekend
yeah get out of this thing quickly and
Jack don't ever do this again I I won't
I learned my lesson yeah good if you can
learn this lesson and make a little
money on the side congratulations and
sorry sorry about your breakup I know
it's painful especially holiday weekend
that's no good
yeah you know yeah five years met her in
college
so I'm sorry about that hey uh my
breakup in college wasn't near as bad as
this one but I went to Vince skill I
went to Vince skill songs so I don't
know
if I did he's got a great song I think
it's I've been trying to get over you or
something like that I may have messed
that up I think Jack's more cardi B guy
you think so I just made that up I don't
really know who cardi B is but I was
going to say I'm impressed that you even
got that name out that's that's great uh
let's go more your neck of the wood
shall we how about Waco Texas uh Marty
is there Marty how can we
help hello Marty hey Marty all right
there we go um hi gentlemen uh so I
tried calling last week um they had me
calling this week uh I spoke to a
smartvestor pro this morning um I'm just
the big thing I'm trying to figure out
right now is getting uh making a career
change I'm looking at uh possibly
starting my own business right now and
um that way I could try and create some
more margin and reduce my working hours
okay so what's the
business um I want to um I want to start
my own private security company private
security yes sir okay and have you any
experience in that field at all I do
okay uh I I'm going to be asking a lot
of dumb questions which is probably good
for somebody as as clueless about this
business as I am uh what kind of
Licensing what kind of uh do you need do
you already have it is that going to
take a while give me give me the the
qualified answer yes so to sign up um I
already became my own private security
agency um uh that was free for me
because I'm a veteran and uh I got my my
most basic level for um security which
doesn't allow me to carry a far um even
though I have my LTC which is weird okay
either way um to be a that's a
non-commission officer I want to to
actually like start doing real security
work I would want to uh get my firearm
uh my commission officer which allows me
to become a firearm eventually I would
want to work up to the top level which
is personal bodyguard yeah have
you I imagine you've done a bunch of
napkin math have you called some guys
who actually own security companies who
run with these guys cuz the guys that I
know I've only know a couple of them all
I hear them talking about is how hard it
is people don't show up they like it's
It's just tough gig have you talked to
those guys and had coffee with them and
taking notes I've tried to I've gotten a
hold of like multiple people that either
friends know or I know and all that and
they all say oh yeah I'll you know I'll
get back with you and I never hear back
all right let me ask you this are you
planning to just be sole proprietor
meaning it's just you your services or
you trying to staff up right away no for
at first it'll just be a a onean show
just me yeah all right but I would like
to grow and expand of course all right
so we got about a minute and a half
what's the heart of your question what
did you need our advice on then well I'm
just trying to um figure out uh I'm
going to be done with baby step 2 here
in a few weeks um you know working on
baby step 3
as well as uh you know looking to try
and move into what are you doing now
what are you doing now and how much you
make um I make
41 uh working as a park ranger for Texas
state parks okay um I I also make
another
12,000 working as a factory worker at
night and then I do a bunch of odd jobs
so you know what I would do I would try
to replace the factory worker at night
and some of the other odd jobs with this
private security detail cuz that's a lot
better money concertall games call
Baylor University and start working some
of their games security and then the
answer Marty then you move on from your
$41,000 job as soon as you can replace
the 41,000 in income through security
which I would guess is pretty quickly
get busy offer your services get out
there um but I think that's when you
make the move but keep the day job until
you can replace that income with a
security job and then don't look to hire
a bunch of people quickly get really
good and premium pay on your own this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey show the
phone number to jump in is8
825-5222 Joins me we're here to answer
your question about your money your work
your relationships your mental health uh
whatever you want to ask about we're not
going to make uh football predictions
for Thanksgiving day that we will not
take those calls just want to point that
out uh let's go to Alicia now who joins
us in Seattle Washington Alicia how can
we
help hi thanks for taking my call I
really appreciate it you bet what's up
um I'm in nursing well getting ready for
nursing school right now I'm working as
a CNA making decent money however I'm
working the baby steps and I'm finding
it hard to get a way to bring in new
income that way I can just pay down debt
as fast as I can without losing it and
I'm just wondering um the first question
is should I sell my car I I don't know
if that's really a stable idea or not so
I'm just wanting some advice on it okay
tell us about how much you owe on the
car and what do you think it's worth uh
I owe
14420 and is I'm getting estimates from
about 6 to
9,000 so I'm wondering would it be worth
it to just have freedom if I pay off
that 4,000 or should I just keep the car
being that you know I'm about to start
nursing school I don't know where I'm
going to be traveling or should I just
suck it up and ride Metro well that's
interesting I was going to ask that next
so the car is only worth 6 to 9,000 eo14
so you'd have to uh viously go get
another smaller loan uh which would
certainly save you a little bit of money
um I would say keep the car I'm thinking
that too cuz Metro is notoriously
unreliable for time and if you have a
shift that you have to be at that's
going to be really tough to do what is
your Metro situation are you close in to
where it's a lot more reliable or is
John right is that kind of a a sketchy
situation right now I'm pretty close I'm
only about uh maybe 3 miles from work
the only thing is I'm looking for new
work because the Grace has left for the
job I currently do but I can't just jump
ship because it currently affords all of
my bills so I'm okay waiting for
something that can actually do that what
other debt do you
have I have credit cards and student
loans and a little bit of medical bills
all right give me the numbers go
smallest to
largest uh the smallest is the medical
bills that's about 3,000 credit card is
5,000 and my student loans are
15378 okay and what you said was is just
not able to make much Headway based on
what you're making now what are you
making now as a
CNA uh before
after uh you you tell me it doesn't
matter to me what give me your you're
after uh when I come home it's roughly
3,000 to 3,400 if I work overtime I can
do that but it's kind of hard to do over
time because I'm in school in school so
what are you what well that's pretty
tight isn't it 3,000 take home it is a
little tight yeah
um how much more schooling do you
have uh a little bit over two years wow
and so you don't have any other you have
no other time during the week to where
you can you can work to make some more
income not really um not in pass my
classes
okay
um this is real time thinking through
this
um I wonder if you paused the nursing
classes would that set you behind that's
an ignorant question because I don't
know how those programs work but if I
could pause it would it would set you
back because I've already wasted two
years not doing what I should have done
that's why I'm being so intense about it
now because I know this is between me
and my next career step is actually
finishing nursing school okay so I I
hear what you're saying so let me say it
this way let's pretend you're running a
marathon and the first two miles of the
marathon you got out pretty slow and you
were talking with your friend
and you were just kind of absorbing
everybody cheering and then you realized
oh no I'm way behind my
pace and you just started sprinting as
fast as you could
go you would make up miles three and
four pretty quick and then at Mile five
you would collapse and
crash what I would want you to do is to
slowly pick up the pace over 26
miles and so you feel like you've wasted
two years I bet you a million bucks you
didn't waste it even if you learn
something really important about
yourself and about what you want and
about who you're going to be and your
purpose you didn't waste it it may not
have invested it the way you would have
wanted to invest that time but it's your
life it's it's you did what you
did it might be and I've counseled
countless students on this it might be
hey if I took six months off of this
program and just work 20 hour days just
worked everybody Place who would hire me
and I got this debt paid off then I
could breathe and then I could be fully
into these nursing program and then
actually when it comes to mile 26 5
years from now you'll be way further
ahead than you are right now you see
what I'm saying you feel like you have
to catch everything up in two years so
you can get on this thing and make this
money and go I want you to play a
10-year game not a two-year game Elicia
that's why I asked the question I don't
mean set you back emotionally I mean set
you back profession you can you can pick
back up is my point if you had to pause
you can pick back back up
yes yeah I I could all right so hold on
I know you're not believing yet but
John's 100% right so let's just run the
numbers can we play the numbers out real
quick sure all right let's just assume
for this example that you've paused
Nursing School uh with you working
overtime busting it what do you think
how much debt do you think you could pay
off each month give me a number that's
don't be modest don't be too aggressive
here give me a modest number that you
think if I was working overtime like
John said how many how much money could
I put towards debt each month what's the
number if I really went at it I'm
thinking close to a th because what I
used to do is just get a second job but
school is in the way of that right now
all right so that's awesome let's just
say you can do a thousand and I know you
can I know you can do a thousand I think
you can do more but I like the modest
number based on that and your numbers
that you gave me you're paying off the
$3,000 medical loan the 5,000 in credit
cards and $14,000 on a car that's 22
Grand that's 22 months nursing is still
going to be waiting on you in fact it's
it's wide open the field they need
nurses like crazy no one's going to
judge you for taking a two a 22-month
pause nobody and you're going to be able
to jump right back in to John's point
though and he's right you either do that
or you're going to be really intense
just trying to survive the next two
years so here's a crazy thing that
happened to me my dad was a policeman
and then became a minister
and money was super tight my whole
childhood and the way I tried to solve
that like I saw what happened to him and
I said I don't want that to happen to me
so I chased a whole bunch of degrees so
I could make a whole bunch of money and
what I ended up doing because of my
fancy degrees allowed me to make more
money I dug an way deeper hole than my
dad could have ever dug for himself and
if you go on this trajectory for 2 years
Ken and I are looking at your numbers
you're going to have to end up falling
backwards on a credit card you are one
FL Tire away one transmission issue away
one I got covid I got the flu and I had
to miss a thing there's no way you can
make these bills so you're going to get
two years from now and you're going to
have dug yourself a deeper hole than you
have right now which means you're going
to have to go make more money and then
somebody's going to say well I just get
your Master's in nursing and because
I've lived in this community I know you
guys and y'all all about education and
Improvement and so dude I you 22 months
kid just mapped out I bet you can make a
plan for 18 months and if you went right
now in January and you took one semester
and then next year off and just said I'm
going to be so maniacal about getting
this debt paid off so that I can start
January of
25 completely debt free and Waltz R into
you you you're going to be standing six
inches taller because nobody will have
claim to you you will be on your own two
feet and I know 18 months feels like a
million years after you just feel like
you blew two years I don't think you
blew two years I think you survived two
years and there's always a Treading
Water season for all of us in our lives
and now you're back on it but that's
just again I've just counseled too many
students who go so hard they dig
themselves such a it's like hitting the
gas in a mud puddle you end up just
digging a bigger hole that's harder to
get out of and that's my fear for you
because your margins are so tight right
now yeah what do you think Alicia they
are tight Everything feels tight yeah
see we want we want we want you to be
free from that yeah I want you to
breathe at night um I I don't think
you're trading two years I think you
look at it as I'm trading two years I
think you're trading some peace of mind
and then when you get into nursing even
more peace when you're actually working
and you're not you're actually enjoying
the work and stacking cash that's what
we're asking you to do bust it hard
pause nursing for the 18 months I think
you can do an 18 maybe less then you
enter into that full-time nursing job
you're debt free that's what we want for
you so hopefully you'll go do that we
believe you can do it Alicia thank you
so much for trusting us you're going to
do great you're going to help a lot of
people this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Dr John deloney
the phone number to jump in is8
825-5222 five our scripture of the day
is from Romans 12:10 be devoted to one
another in love honor one another above
yourselves our quote of the day and this
is fitting uh we lost one of the great
ladies uh in America yesterday rosn
Carter President Jimmy Carter what a
couple yeah I don't know how long
they've been married it Escapes Me Right
Now I want to say it's close to 70 years
I could be wrong on that um never had a
chance to meet her I had the privilege
of interviewing President Jimmy Carter
on the very first radio show I ever did
crazy story about that but uh I don't
care where you fall on the political
aisle you're talking about two of the
kindest nicest humblest people on the
planet it was sad to see that rosn
Carter pass away and there a couple that
just dedicated their lives to serving
other people yeah I mean the guy's
presiden see uh you know historically uh
arguable people criticized him and he
did maybe his greatest work post
presidency which speaks to the man and
she was right there with him anyway
great great people I know the people of
Plains Georgia any Georgian right now
proud of of of Jimmy and and Roslin
Carter so anyway the quote from Roslin
Carter do what you can to show you care
about other people and you will make our
world a better place I think she modeled
that clear as that's right yeah yeah so
fantastic all right let's go to Phoenix
Arizona now Jesus is there Jesus how can
we
help um I had a couple major questions
but main question I did have is me and
my wife are just starting on the baby
steps welcome to the cult man
welcome I said welcome to this welcome
to this wild crew man you threw to you
yeah welcome how can we help threw me
off threw me you're doing great doing
great I'm excited to have a new gang
member dude it's
awesome so what what we want to try to
do is um and I know in baby steps one
it's said to do $1,000 in an emergency
fund
and me I've done dead collections
customer services sales for 10 years uh
my wife she doesn't know anything about
how well to do her finances because I've
helped her whenever she moved down here
to
Arizona but now we're just starting with
the baby steps we're already married
we've been married for over two years
now um been together for over 10 in
general so whenever we started um we're
kind of debating a thousand to say into
a savings account and leave that alone
for
emergencies and our M we want to try to
at least do uh at least a month or three
months worth of all of our bills into
one uh for savings for that total amount
and then start with the snowball or the
Avalanche effect uh to paying off our
debts how much do you owe
man uh grand total uh about
67,000 what you
make uh both of us together
72,000 okay so we have benefits we have
certain benefits of our company that we
do because we both work at the same
place we um we carpol so it saves US
money sure uh we also get out benefits
like an extra $20 per you know $40 for
us for Walmart runs since we have those
um but in regards to that we're just
trying to debate where to start and what
to start with yeah so
um I you the fact that a $20 benefit is
something that you guys hang your hat on
it's not a it's not a bad thing that
tells me how much you're tread in
water and when I look at 67 in the hole
and
72 y'all are y'all are leveraged almost
dollar for
dooll like your chest is pretty tight
isn't it
uh somewhat but it changed we've
actually originally changed a lot of
that I used to do over the road truck
driving okay so I used to easily make $5
to $2,000 a week okay and that was
nothing my wife would be at home she
would work or we would go on vacation
together technically her vacation my job
okay so we go over the road five months
that kind of thing I did have a truck a
old Dodge Ram I used to have uh that
was
$858 per month so I got rid of it traded
in for a new vehicle that I purchased a
couple months ago and took that out of
the equan where it's not 858 a month now
it's 437 a month instead of saving me
about a couple hundred bucks it does but
you're still playing a month-to-month
game and so for the baby steps to work
you have to literally throw out
everything you know this is not a math
problem and what I would suggest to you
with all due respect like high five like
I'll buy the next round like so I'm not
that's not me talking down to you it's
just two dudes across the table from
each other at the bar
right the way you've done it hasn't
worked and so when you think of only
having a th000 bucks in emergency that
should scare you to
death it's it's intentional because
we're not doing a math game here we're
doing a psychology game
because the math game is so rigged in
all these other businesses favor that a
$20 shopping credit to Walmart makes you
feel like a
benefit or hey I went from an $800
payment down to a $400 payment look
who's winning now and I will tell you
the finance department at the car
dealership that's selling you
depreciating assets continues to
win and so when I say when we say $1,000
that is in case like a tire blows that's
in case something we just need to hobble
down the road as fast as you
can and what we're doing is we're we're
that's why we we say smallest to largest
a snowball the the snowball method here
we're not looking at the Avalanche stuff
and what do you have the highest
interest rate all that nonsense because
that's a math game and math games don't
work look at America we're broke the
only game that works is a psychology
game and if you pay off one little bitty
credit card you're you're you see a the
light at the end of the tunnel gets a
tiny little bit brighter then you pay
off the next one you pay off the next
one and you get a ad in the paper and
you're or in the mailbox and you're like
forget this and you get the next one and
you start to get these little bitty wins
and that's little wins are the key to
psychological Health it's the key to
marriage Health it's the key to
Financial Health and so you thinking you
went from 800 to 450 like you you won
you you technically improved your
financial position a car dealership
still owns my friend
Jesus because if you don't want to if
you get sick tomorrow they're going to
want their money and if your boss says
hey I need you to cut some corners and
do something a little bit Shady they
want their money and if they don't
they're going to come to your house and
take your car from you see what I'm
saying so we're like Ken and I Ramsey
we're playing a whole different ball
game and that is how what is the
quickest path to absolute freedom nobody
owns Jesus
period that's what we're aiming for okay
you see what I'm saying totally
different ball
game and we've helped millions and
millions tactic is trying to basically
ping pin some of the stuff that we can
provide but also you know hey you know
you only have this as an emergency fund
all rest you need to get rid of get rid
of that car you need to get rid of that
SUV now you're talking
motorcycle payment now you're
talking I've already paid off my um my
student loan debts already whenever I
was doing over the road ex excellent
good work man so you got it in you dude
you got it you just got to get it you
got to start following a plan yeah
here's what happens there the intensity
that you have to run with after this
debt uh and the intentionality of the
baby steps together come to it gives you
tremendous tremendous momentum and
here's the deal let me just answer this
practically too because if you have to
dip into that $1,000 emergency fund uh
you have to wipe it out and then build
it back up there's going to be some life
emergencies but it's the intentionality
and the intensity that you have to get
after it which is what you win the day
so it's you don't try to game the the
process the reason Dave put it in place
like this is because statistically it
works Jesus you're a guy that goes to
the gym every day and you lift every day
here's what you need you need a
that you can follow cuz you're already
in it you can do it hang on the line
we're going to give you Financial Peace
University all nine lessons as our gift
and we're going to hook you in your new
wife up with every dollar the greatest
budgeting app on planet Earth I want you
to watch these videos follow them to the
letter and my brother you're going to be
debt free okay go get them good stuff Dr
John deloney I'm Ken Coleman James
Charles and all the guys in the booth
thank you guys for keeping us on the air
and America thank you for tuning in we
do this for you it is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
n